Poo. Everybody does it...
I don't.
...but with the exception of new
parents and six-year-olds,
most of us don't talk about it.
But could our number twos
be the answer
to some of the world's
biggest problems?
The average adult flushes away
730 litres of pee
and around 91kg of faeces every year.
But are we missing a trick?
In Ancient Rome, no human waste
went to waste.
Untreated excrement was used
as manure in kitchen gardens
while urine was used
to produce fabric.
In Henry VIII's time, one
of the country's top positions
was Groom of the Stool.
Wiping the king's bottom
was well worth it
for the benefit of having his ear.
"About that castle..."
Cesspits were emptied overnight
by gong farmers
who sold the content
to local farmers.
Urine was collected
and used to soften leather.
While it's probably sensible to leave
untreated manure
in the past where it belongs -
think of the pathogens -
we can learn from our predecessors'
attitude to poo.
It could be the solution to some of
our most pressing problems of today.
Let's start with our need for energy.
Unlike solar or wind power,
which can be unreliable,
all it takes is a healthy
fibre intake
to ensure a constant supply of poo.
Now that's a whole
other kind of wind power.
The sludge left behind after
sewage is processed
is good raw material
for generating methane.
Modern treatment plants
add bacteria to the sludge,
generating bio-gas,
which can be piped to homes
or used to power vehicles.
It's a much cleaner fuel
than petrol or diesel.
While poo has plenty of uses,
there's a reason wee is number one.
Seventy two percent of global
water use is in agriculture
and population increases
coupled with climate change
will only exacerbate
the demand for water.
Some countries could face having
populations displaced
by water scarcity within the decade.
In addition to the two litres of pee
each adult in the UK produces daily,
each adult also sends
around 140 litres of water
used at home down the drain.
Could recycling that water save the
planet from apocalyptic droughts?
Absolutely.
The technology is available
and already in use.
Israel currently captures
almost 90% of used water
which is recycled to provide
a whopping 56,000 Olympic swimming
pools' worth of water annually
for agricultural use.
Speaking of agriculture,
every living thing relies
on phosphorous to survive.
But due to chronic overmining, it's a
rapidly declining natural resource
which can't be replenished.
The US, China and India might
run out of their domestic supplies
in the next generation.
Without adding this vital
nutrient to farmland,
humanity could only produce around
half the food it does today.
We could however emulate
our ancestors
and return our sewage to the soil,
making use of solutions
such as composting toilets,
or the nutrient-rich dried residue
left over from bio-gas generation.
Reinventing the toilet could
also be a gamechanger
for 4.2 billion people
currently living without access
to safe sanitation.
Innovative toilet designs that
operate without water
could help prevent the deaths of an
estimated 800 children under five
each day.
Bill Gates predicts this
developing toilet market
would not only be lifesaving
but lucrative.
By 2030, toilets could become
a six billion US dollar market,
with every dollar spent
providing a $5 return.
While poo remains a word that
never fails to raise a giggle,
your faecal matter
is no laughing matter.
If we act now, poo may very well
help to save the planet.